Rồi giòn nước cơ quan năng lượng bên từ của tế, ER, ông Ruffran Gossy,
vừa bây tỏ về vọng tránh cửa vị trí, tổng thực kỳ lịch hợp quốc trong những kỹ tởi,
với mục tiêu khôi phục quý tín và nân cao hiệu quả hả nốc của tổ chức của tế lợn nhất thế giới.
Theo ông Gossy đang tổn tại một tức tế đảng lông ai rằng,
lịch hợp quốc đang phằng mặt trong hầu hết các nỗ lực hoa dài, các cuộc sống luật quân sử,
đảng dễn ra trên toàn cầu.
Theo ông Thay Vì chào đổi cách kết cận chỉ chết từ trong mình đúng.
Vì hợp quý chỉ đổi thoại với tất cả các bên linh quan trong mỏ của xung đột mới là chưa quả để đả được hoa bình.
Ông Ruffran Gossy, sing ngà mua in chỉ trăm sóm mi mốt, của tịch tạch hả tỷ nà,
tình công tác tại bụng anh rằng nước này phụ chắc các vấn đề hạnh nhân và giải chưu quân biệt.
Sau đó, ông dưới vài chào đại dễ, là hạnh địa tạy nhiều cơ quan của tế trong đó có ER và cà cơ quan tọn cầu về cầm thử hạnh nhân.
Từ năm 2020, ông chờ thành tổng giòn đốc ERR trong khi đó tổng thực dilih hấp quốc luôn,
giải thích đoạn, sing năm 2019, quên thủ tưởng vô đồng nhà ông đầm giấm trộp viện người đầu đến
hấp quốc tưởng năm 2020 và sẽ kết túc là kêu hai vào năm sau 2020.